this group of covet 19 support
volunteers in bangkok
is getting ready for another busy shift
as thai hospitals buckle under the
strain of coronavirus patients
they're run off their feet every day
they receive around 100 calls from
desperate covert patients
unable to get help
we realize how hard working and how
tired doctors and nurses are
what we're trying to do is help relieve
some of the burden
before all cases had to be sent to
hospital today
there are no hospital beds so we
volunteered to help out
their first call takes them to a woman
who's having trouble breathing
they provide her with an oxygen tank
then it's on to the house of another
woman whose sister is sick with covid
she says their mother has already died
of the virus
my mother showed bad symptoms from the
beginning i called and called to tell
them that my mum couldn't handle this
anymore but nobody came
the nurses kept saying there were no
beds
in bangkok alone around 20 000 people
are currently waiting for a hospital bed
after keeping covert at bay when it
first emerged
thailand is now going through its worst
stretch of the pandemic
fueled by the delta variant daily new
infections are going up and up
hitting another record high on monday
vaccinations are progressing at a slow
pace
only about five percent of the
population is fully immunized
this vaccination center in bangkok was
overrun after it started accepting
walk-ins last week
public anger has forced the head of the
national vaccine institute to apologize
for mishandling the vaccination campaign
he also promised to ramp up vaccine
procurement by joining the kovacs
distribution scheme
so thailand will start receiving vaccine
donations next year
for those risking their lives working on
the front line of the pandemic
that will seem like a long way off
the pandemic in thailand has contributed
to more dissatisfaction with prime
minister
prayut chanocha with protesters once
again taking to the streets
they risk infection and heavy penalties
for ignoring coronavirus restrictions
this month marks one year since the
emergence of the biggest
challenge to the military establishment
when activists called for democratic
reform
ducking for cover in bangkok as police
fire water cannon
rubber bullets and tear gas to stop
protesters
reaching government house defying a ban
on public gatherings
they had assembled at the democracy
monument in the thai capital
to restate their calls for prime
minister prayut chanocha to step down
the clashes mark a year since protesters
first took to the streets on mass
with their demands for democratic reform
posing the biggest challenge to the
prime minister
since he took power in a 2014 coup
the protests also took on a taboo topic
the king
criticizing the royal family is a crime
in thailand punishable by lengthy prison
sentences
but in a show of defiance a group of
protesters installed a plaque near the
grand palace
which read this country belongs to the
people and not the king
the bold gesture was accompanied by
speeches and slogans
challenging the king's spending and
power
a confrontation that was soon greeted
with an official rebuke
by october the government had issued an
emergency decree
designed to end the protests on
bangkok's streets
[Applause]
[Music]
the government deems it necessary to
declare a state of emergency
our goal is to ensure we can act against
the protests because they've turned
violent
there are many things happening that
have never happened before
weeks later the most prominent protest
leaders face charges of insulting the
monarchy
as the monarchy uses the law to shut us
up it means they're afraid of us
speaking the truth
the measures quelled but did not crush
the pro-democracy
movement and new demonstrations have
erupted throughout 2021
dissatisfaction over the government's
handling of the pandemic
is now adding fuel to the discontent
thailand's experiencing its most deadly
wave since the virus emerged
driven by the delta variant vaccines are
in short supply
and the economic impact is biting hard
joining us is khad satra saying
editor-in-chief of thai inquirer
khad the protesters are making a
calculation they're willing to risk
legal consequences and contracting covid
why do you think this is happening
um i believe that they've gotten to a
point where they think that you know
there's nothing it's not going to get
any worse for them i mean
we're we're in a free-falling economy
people are out of jobs people are really
desperate
people don't have enough to eat and then
protesters just say enough is enough
they need a change of governance they
need a change of leadership
not only to be able to handle you know
the situation with covid which has
gone terribly over the last six months
but also because the political system
has come to a head
and they've gotten to a point where they
think there needs to be a wholesale
change in politics here where the
military
and the conservative establishment is no
longer involved in the governance of the
country
now last summer's protests lost a bit of
momentum in later months with people
staying at home
where do you think this second summer of
protests will take the movement
well the reason that it sort of simmered
down was
uh there was a multitude of reasons
rather um
first of all coveted situation came back
into play and people weren't willing to
risk as much
back in let's say october or november of
last year
the protesters also encountered a lot of
physical resistance from from the armed
forces whether it's the police or the
soldiers
so a lot of people were worried about
you know physical contact or coming into
bodily harm
now that it's gotten now that it's a
year later and the situation hasn't
gotten any better in terms of the
economy and covet i think people are
more willing to risk
you know their livelihoods themselves um
in the pursuit of something
that they think will bring about
positive change for the country
where it takes us i don't know the
country is still in lockdown
until at least um the end of this month
um there's plans by the government to
open up by october if that is the case
and if the kovitz situation does die
down
i don't think that the anger that the
people on the streets feel
is is going to subside with the
reopening of the country i think if
anything it's going to it's going to
make more people come out of the streets
because the
covet situation is under control because
they're willing to
to go out and let the government know
about their demands and their right to
be heard
now the movement has largely been viewed
as one being driven by
students with the establishment middle
class not
on board do you see this changing based
on what you just told me
absolutely if you had asked me last year
whether that was the case i would say
you're absolutely correct that this was
a largely
student-inspired student-pushed
student-led movement
as far back as let's say october of 2020
fast forward a year and and if anything
everyone is angry now not just
the students the middle class are angry
because their businesses are closed
the working class are angry because they
have no jobs they have no access to
income they have no access to loans
which has been prohibitive
they have no access to food and basic
necessities and
and even even the conservative
establishment people who aren't directly
in the government are becoming more
angry and becoming more upset with this
government
because of their mismanagement because
there's no more tourism money
because the country's been closed down
for almost two years now
because they don't because their
businesses aren't allowed to operate the
way they want it to
so a crop the cross-section of thai
society is extremely upset
with this current government and i don't
see that changing and i don't see the
economic situation improving
miraculously overnight so if anything
more people are angry now and i think
the students if they
if they voice their message correctly
they're going to gain a lot of
supporters
now i want to turn to the pandemic more
directly
you're there give us a sense of how you
and everyone around you
are feeling in terms of safety in terms
of your health
well i my team and i at time choir have
been
working from home now for almost
eight months straight um because of the
coveted situation because we don't want
to risk it
the only people that are out in the
field are our photographers and our
videographers
who who have been vaccinated so it's
it's
it's a tough situation people are angry
and the the reason they're most angry is
because the vaccine rollout has been
so slow um uh there's been a
series of blunders by the ministry of
public health um
not ordering the right vaccines not
ordering enough vaccines
so and and the situation just goes from
bad news to bad news so until
our entire population can be vaccinated
it's just
it's just not going to be any better
with even with the lockdown
in terms of our daily lives um right now
we're entering the most severe phase of
the newest lockdown so malls are closed
restaurants are shuttered
it's been rough um but but and
until we can get the entire population
vaccinated i don't see it getting better
got it cod sacha sayon thank you so much
for joining us
absolutely thank you for having me
and here's a roundup of how the pandemic
is impacting other parts of southeast
asia
the region has become an epicenter of
the contagious delta
variant malaysia says it won't extend
its coronavirus emergency beyond august
1st
the country's parliament is convening
this week for the first time
this year indonesia has announced that
some coronavirus measures will be
relaxed even though it's still grappling
with a huge outbreak
salons and restaurants with outdoor
areas will be among the businesses
allowed to reopen
and residents in vietnam's economic hub
ho chi minh city
face a strict overnight curfew from
today
they are required to stay at home from 6
p.m
to 6 a.m that's it for today
as you know there's always more on our
website dw dot com forward slash asia
and you can catch us on social media
we'll leave you with pictures of
buddhist monks in thailand
lighting candles for the asana bucha
festival
with of course prayers for those
battling kovid
thank you for watching
[Music]
you